Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. What rhubarb, senna or what purgative drug Will scour these English heads? Now that's the line spoken by Macbeth in Shakespeare's Scottish play that in May 1849 contributed to one of the worst riots in the history of New York City,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。什么大黄、番泻叶或其他什么通便药才能清洗这些英国人的头脑呢？这句话是莎士比亚苏格兰剧作中麦克白说的台词，在1849年5月，它引发了纽约历史上最严重的暴动之一，
the Astor Place Riot of 1849. Tom Holland, are you familiar with the Astor Place Riot? This is a, what, a riot about? About my bed. About my bed. No. Yeah, so this is a bizarre but true story. So mid-19th century America,
即1849年的阿斯特坊骚乱。汤姆·霍兰，你熟悉阿斯特坊骚乱吗？这是一个，什么，关于什么的骚乱？关于我的床。关于我的床。不。是的，这是一个离奇但真实的 Så故事。19世纪中叶的美国，
all sorts of sort of nativist passions and so on, anti-English passions, and there's this great row in New York between the supporters of two actors, Edwin Forrest, who's the sort of all-American hero, and William Charles McCready, who is batting for Britain. And the great crowds who cheer their man on, who think that their man is better at Shakespeare,
各种本土主义情绪等等，反英情绪高涨，纽约的两位演员的支持者之间爆发了一场大争吵，一位是纯正的美利坚英雄埃德温·福雷斯特，另一位是为英国效力的威廉·查尔斯·麦克雷迪。大批群众为他们支持的人欢呼，他们认为自己支持的人更擅长演莎士比亚，
better at playing Macbeth. That's a great reason to have a riot. I mean, you've got to have a riot. You know what they shouted? No. From the stalls? Down with the codfish aristocracy. I think that's a kind of anti-English line of some kind.
更擅长扮演麦克白。这倒是个闹事的绝佳理由。我的意思是，你非得闹一场不可。你知道他们喊了什么吗？不知道。从包厢里传出来的？打倒鳕鱼贵族。我觉得这某种程度上是一种反英台词。
So, yes. So, our subject is the Scottish play. It is. Which has inspired passions down the ages. And rumours of curses and all kinds of things. Witches. Well, actually, you know the reason I really wanted to do this was because they are made a theatre in London, which is my favourite theatre. Favourite theatre.
所以，是的。我们的主题是苏格兰剧。是的。它历代激起人们的激情。还有关于诅咒和各种传闻的流言。女巫。其实，你知道我真正想做这个节目的原因，是因为伦敦的一个剧院，那是我最喜欢的剧院。最喜欢的剧院。
Yeah, I do have a favourite theatre. And they they were due to kick off with a performance of Macbeth today with Saoirse Ronan. Yeah. As Lady Macbeth. And I had tickets and it's just been cancelled because of. Because of Covid. Because of Covid outbreak. I mean, the whole play hasn't.
对，我确实有一个最喜欢的剧院。他们原本定于今天以西尔莎·罗南主演的《麦克白》拉开帷幕。是的。饰演麦克白夫人。我买票了，但因为原因刚刚取消了。因为新冠。因为新冠疫情爆发。我的意思是，整部剧并没有……
But the tickets that I had have been cancelled. That's very sad. So that is a shame. I should say to the listeners, this is a very unusual podcast, isn't it? It is. Because we're actually for once in the same room. It is.
但我买的票被取消了。真令人难过。所以这真是个遗憾。我得跟听众们说，这是一个非常罕见的播客，对吧？确实。因为我们破天荒地坐在同一个房间里。确实。
Which is a bit weird. So we're really taking a punt here because obviously we're doing it on Macbeth, which is incredibly unlucky. So something awful is clearly going to happen over the course of recording this podcast. but also we're having to adjust to actually yeah kind of looking at each other it's very disconcerting actually just kind of sitting side by side talking to each other in a way that you just I've completely forgotten how to do yeah
这感觉有点诡异。所以我们这次真的是在冒险，因为我们显然是在录制《麦克白》，这极其不吉利。所以录制这个播客的过程中显然会发生可怕的事情。但同时我们也不得不适应，实际上，是的，看着对方，这其实非常让人不知所措，就是这样并排坐着互相说话，用一种你根本……我完全忘了该怎么做了，对吧。
you just wouldn't sit like this in real life would you no I mean not that this is not real life but anyway um so Macbeth so I but the other reason I wanted to do it is because I think that um the historical figure of Macbeth which lies behind the kind of bloodstained tyrant of Shakespeare's play he wasn't at all a bloodstained tyrant he was actually a pretty good king I mean he was such a good king that in the 11th century he was able to go on pilgrimage to Rome which is kind of the measure of of how well your your kingdom is doing and you can leave it behind yeah exactly so the so so the question is why how and why did this very effective um really quite popular king become you know this kind of byword for tyranny yeah um and the answer to that question i i propose goes to the heart of the making of Scotland so the fashioning of
你在现实生活中根本不会这样坐，对吧？不，也不是说这不是现实生活，但不管怎样，嗯……所以麦克白……我……我另外想做这个的原因是，我认为……莎士比亚戏剧中那个血腥暴君背后的历史人物麦克白，他根本不是什么血腥暴君，他其实是个相当不错的国王。我的意思是，他是个如此优秀的国王，以至于在11世纪他能够去罗马朝圣，这可以说是衡量你的王国治理得有多好、你可以抛下它不管的尺度。对，没错。所以……所以问题是，这个非常高效、实际上相当受欢迎的国王，为什么、如何以及为什么会变成这种代表暴政的代名词呢？是的，嗯……而我对这个问题的回答，我认为触及了苏格兰形成的本质，也就是
Scotland out of the various constituent parts that make it up okay so before we get into that I'll just say for the listeners we will talk about the play Tom mentioned very ominously that he thought we might get halfway through and he would have got them at Beth's birth which I think is bad planning. But we're going to get to the play probably in the second half and we'll talk about the witches. We'll talk about James I. We'll talk about the Shakespearean context, the curse, and a couple of notable productions of Macbeth. But first, Tom sent me a message yesterday saying that he had gone down a rabbit hole of Scottish medieval politics.
苏格兰从构成它的各个部分中被塑造出来的过程。好吧，在我们深入探讨之前，我先跟听众说一下，我们会讨论这部剧。汤姆非常不祥地提到，他觉得我们可能进行到一半麦克白就出生了，我觉得这计划得很糟糕。但我们大概会在下半部分聊到这部剧，我们会谈到女巫。我们会谈到詹姆斯一世。我们会谈到莎士比亚的时代背景、诅咒，以及几部著名的《麦克白》制作。但首先，汤姆昨天给我发了一条消息，说他陷入了苏格兰中世纪政治的兔子洞。
And I want to see him clamber. Well, yeah. So obviously all early medieval history is incredibly complicated. Yeah. A, because the sources are often very sparse. Yeah. And B, because they're often overwritten by people who have a kind of set interest in rewriting them.
我想看他怎么爬出来。好吧，是的。显然所有早期中世纪历史都极其复杂。是的。A，因为史料通常非常稀疏。是的。B，因为它们经常被那些带着特定重写意图的人篡改。
Yes. So it's very difficult and complex. And I think, you know, I put my hand up that I know the history of early medieval England much better than I do the history of early medieval Scotland. And there's a similar process by which kind of fragmentary kingdoms start to cohere. And then like Wessex and Mercia and England. Exactly, become England. So a similar process happens in Scotland, but it's more complicated in Scotland because in Scotland you have people speaking basically different languages so to be very very reductive yeah if you think of Scotland
是的。所以这非常困难和复杂。我想，你知道，我举手承认我对早期中世纪英格兰历史的了解远胜于早期中世纪苏格兰历史。而且存在一个类似的进程，即各种碎片化的王国开始凝聚在一起。然后就像威塞克斯、麦西亚和英格兰一样。没错，变成了英格兰。所以苏格兰也发生了类似的过程，但在苏格兰更复杂，因为在苏格兰，人们基本上说不同的语言。所以说得非常非常简化，是的，如果你想到苏格兰，
you think of the lowlands and the highlands and then you quarter it so the um the southeast corner Lothian up to up to the Firth of Forth is basically a part of the kingdom of Northumbria, which is English speaking. And so the borough in Edinburgh reflects, you know, it's like a kind of the borough that Anglo-Saxon kings built. They're kind of fortified marketplaces. So that's... Middlesbrough. Yeah.
你就会想到低地和高地，然后你把它四分：嗯……东南角洛锡安一直到福斯湾，基本上是诺森布里亚王国的一部分，那里说英语。所以爱丁堡的自治市镇反映了，你知道，这就像盎格鲁-撒克逊国王建造的自治市镇。它们是一种坚固的集市。所以那就是……米德尔斯堡。是的。
And so Edinburgh was for a long a kind of a Northumbrian stronghold. Then you think of the um the southwest so uh strathclyde strathclyde right and that is the the it's it's a welsh-speaking kingdom with the great rock of dumbarton yeah um alt clut uh the rock of the clyde yeah incredibly romantic then the uh the northeast of the of the highlands uh you've got a kind of great mountain range going through the middle, kind of separating the highlands. On one side, the western side of that, you've got the kingdom of Dalriata, which is Gaelic speaking, and has very, very strong links to Northern Ireland. And then on the other side, you have mysterious people who the romans knew as picts yeah and um in due course the picts come to call themselves picts they kind of appropriate 1066 and
所以爱丁堡长期以来一直是诺森布里亚的一个据点。然后你想想……西南地区，也就是……斯特拉斯克莱德，斯特拉斯克莱德对吧，那是……这是一个说威尔士语的王国，有着邓巴顿巨岩，是的，克莱德岩，极其浪漫。然后……高地的东北部，你中间有一条巨大的山脉，某种程度上把高地隔开。在它的一侧，也就是西侧，你拥有达尔里阿达王国，那里说盖尔语，与北爱尔兰有着非常非常紧密的联系。而在另一侧，你有一群神秘的人，罗马人称他们为皮克特人，是的，嗯，随着时间的推移，皮克特人开始自称为皮克特人，他们某种程度上把《1066和
all that absolutely the picts and the scots so the scots so the scots is the name that the people of dalriada apply to themselves but the complexity here is that the Scotty were originally Irish yes I remember that okay so that's also very complicated and and they derived their name from Scotter do you know who Scotter was no she was the Egyptian princess who discovered Moses in the bulrushes and she is then yeah it's unexpected unexpected so she is then supposed to have travelled to Ireland and established this royal line. Unlikely, I would say. Implausible, as your father would say.
这一切》占为己有。绝对的，皮克特人和苏格兰人。所以苏格兰人，所以“苏格兰人”是达尔里阿达人对自己的称呼。但这里的复杂之处在于，最初的苏格兰人（Scotty）实际上是爱尔兰人。是的，我记得这个。好吧，这也是非常复杂的，他们的名字来源于斯科特（Scotter）。你知道斯科特是谁吗？不知道。她是在芦苇丛中发现摩西的埃及公主，然后她……是的，这出乎意料，出乎意料。然后她据说去了爱尔兰并建立了这个王室血统。我觉得不太可能。用你父亲的话说，这难以置信。
So the kings of Dalriada claim a line of descent from the Irish or Scots. From ancient Egypt. Ultimately from ancient Egypt, because it's a marker of class now in fact this is not true or at least the archaeological evidence suggests it's not true so all so there's there's there are kind of tales of the irish colonizing dalriada right but there is no archaeological evidence for this just whatsoever you you were right you have gone down a rabbit hole i know i know i know. I know. But this is all complicated
所以达尔里阿达的国王声称他们的血统来自爱尔兰人或苏格兰人。来自古埃及。最终来自古埃及，因为这是阶级的标志。事实上，这并不是真的，至少考古证据表明这不是真的。所以，所有……有关于爱尔兰人殖民达尔里阿达的故事，对吧？但没有任何考古证据证明这一点。你确实陷入了一个兔子洞。我知道，我知道，我知道。我知道。但这一切都很复杂，
because it's all about basically kind of kings manufacturing backstories for themselves. So which bit is Macbeth from? Okay. So just, we'll come to that. But just keep in mind that you've got
因为这完全关乎国王们为自己编造背景故事。那麦克白是哪部分的？好吧。稍等，我们马上会讲到。但只要记住你拥有
the Picts, you've got the Scots, then you've got the Picts, you've got the Scots, then you've got the British, the Welsh-speaking Britons of Strathclyde, and then you've got the English of Northumbria. Okay. And this is the kind of st up all the rubble fashion it together and construct a new kingdom the new kingdom of england yes the same process basically happens when the vikings attack because because they they smash they smash up um northumbria as you'll know from burner cornwall yes and and basically bambra is the kind of only survivor. It's kind of semi-independent.
皮克特人、苏格兰人，然后皮克特人、苏格兰人、布立吞人——斯特拉斯克莱德说威尔士语的布立吞人，然后是诺森布里亚的英国人。好的。这就是这种把所有废墟拼凑在一起并构建一个新王国的过程——新的英格兰王国。是的，当维京人进攻时，基本上也会发生同样的进程，因为他们——他们粉碎了……正如你从伯纳德·康威尔那里知道的，诺森布里亚被他们粉碎了，班堡可以说是唯一的幸存者。它有点半独立。
They attack and sack the fortress of Dumbarton. So the kingdom of the Britons is, I mean, it's patched together, but it's a shadow of its former self. That's Trask Live, isn't it? Yes. And there's a battle in which an alliance of the Dariardans, so the Scottish and the Pictish kings, are attacked by the Vikings
他们进攻并洗劫了邓巴顿要塞。所以布立吞人的王国，我的意思是，它拼凑在一起，但已经是昔日影子的缩影。那是斯特拉斯克莱德，对吧？是的。有一场战役，达尔里阿达人（即苏格兰人）和皮克特人国王的联盟遭到维京人进攻，
and kill both the kings of Pictland and Dalriarda. And I was reading a history of early medieval Scotland and it's an absolutely classic kind of sentence of the kind that you get in histories of early medieval Scotland. And it said, this is one of the most decisive battles in british history however we have no idea when it was fought or where right or who was killed yeah to even know so we don't even know the names of the king right but basically all right story so
皮克特兰和达尔里阿达的国王双双阵亡。我当时在读一本关于早期中世纪苏格兰的历史书，里面有一句非常经典的句子，就是那种你在早期中世纪苏格兰历史书里能读到的句子。它说，这是不列颠历史上最具决定性的战役之一，然而我们既不知道它是何时或何地打的，也不知道谁被杀死了。甚至连国王的名字都不知道。所以基本上，好吧……故事……
all of these kingdoms either get kind of smashed to pieces or decapitated yeah and out of this carnage yeah there emerges a shadowy figure um please tell me this is my birth no no it's a guy called kenaid mcalpin who is commemorated as kenneth mcalpin yeah and this inaugurates a wave of people called kenneth and malcolm it does we're hundreds of years away from at this point right uh yeah so we're about 870 so we're hundreds of years away from a Beth at this point, right? Yeah, so we're about 870. So we're about 100 years, 120 years from his birth. Okay, but we're getting there. We're getting there. Because the thing about the thing about Kenneth McAlpin, yeah, is that he establishes a line of kings. But also, he seems to have fused the Dalriada and the Pictish traditions.
所有这些王国要么被粉碎成碎片，要么被斩首，是的，在这场血腥屠杀中，是的，浮现出了一个模糊的人物，请告诉我这是麦克白。不，不，是一个叫肯尼思·麦克亚尔平的家伙，他被当作肯尼思·麦克亚尔平来纪念。确实如此，这就开启了一股名叫肯尼思和马尔科姆的人名浪潮。确实。此时我们距离……距离麦克白还有好几百年呢，对吧？哦，是的，所以我们大约在公元870年，所以此时距离麦克白还有好几百年，对吧？是的，所以我们大约在公元870年。所以距离他的出生大约有100年、120年。好吧，但我们在接近了。我们在接近。因为关于……关于肯尼思·麦克亚尔平的事，是的，在于他建立了一个国王世系。而且，他似乎融合了达尔里阿达和皮克特人的传统。
So people debate whether he was a Pict who spoke Gaelic, whether he was a Gael who kind of had married into the Picts. I mean, it's unconfusing. But basically he's able to... So he's either a Pict who spoke Gaelic or a Gael who spoke Pictish. He doesn't speak Pictish. He definitely doesn't speak Pictish because the significant thing that happens
所以人们争论他是说盖尔语的皮克特人，还是与皮克特人通婚的盖尔人。我的意思是，这令人困惑。但基本上他能够……所以他要么是说盖尔语的皮克特人，要么是说皮克特语的盖尔人。他不说皮克特语。他绝对不说皮克特语，因为发生的一件重要事情是，
is that over the course of the century that follows, Pictish starts to vanish. Okay, let's not get into Pictish okay he definitely doesn't speak Pictish because because the significant thing that happens is that over the course of the century that follows Pictish starts to vanish okay let's not get into Pictish no I know but but but the tradition the tradition that comes to be told is that the Gaels had conquered the Picts and kind of wiped them out which is why Pictish again this is this is a kind of back projection of what seems to happen which is that there is a kind of pooling of Pictish and Dariadan identities and interests the kings who who follow Kenneth MacAlpine yeah most of whom are called either Malcolm or Kenneth very very confusingly they're able to establish this kind of kingdom that that that combines the best of the Pictish and and the Scottish traditions but because it's it's uh it's Gaelic speaking
在随后的一个世纪里，皮克特语开始消失。好吧，我们别扯皮克特语了。好吧，他绝对不说皮克特语，因为发生的一件重要事情是，在随后的一个世纪里，皮克特语开始消失。好吧，我们别扯皮克特语了。不，我知道，但是……流传下来的传统是，盖尔人征服了皮克特人并基本上消灭了他们，这就是为什么皮克特语——再次说明，这是一种对似乎发生的事情的回溯性投射，也就是皮克特和达尔里阿达的身份与利益出现了一种融合。跟随肯尼思·麦克亚尔平之后的国王们，是的，他们大多数人非常令人困惑地被称为马尔科姆或肯尼思，他们能够建立起这样一个王国，结合了皮克特和苏格兰传统的精华。但因为它是……它是说盖尔语的，
yeah it comes to be known as Alba which is the Gaelic for the whole of Great Britain but it comes to be particularly associated related to Albion yes so initially so it's Alba is the kind of Gaelic version of Albion yeah uh but but the kingdom of Alba comes to be this this Dalriard and Pictish um okay so so that's what's going on then over the course of the 9th century obviously you have the the English state emerging and becoming increasingly powerful um so you have Athelstan for instance yeah who launches an invasion to impose English supremacy on it and becomes emperor of all Britain becomes emperor of all Britain uh but the but that his successors discover that they
所以它后来被称为阿尔巴（Alba），这是整个大不列颠的盖尔语名称，但它后来变得与阿尔比恩（Albion）紧密相关。是的，所以最初……阿尔巴是阿尔比恩的盖尔语版本，是的。但阿尔巴王国成为了这个达尔里阿达和皮克特的……好吧，所以这就是当时的情况。然后在9世纪期间，显然英国国家崛起并变得日益强大。所以例如你有埃塞尔斯坦，是的，他发动了一次入侵，将英国的统治强加于其上，并成为了全不列颠的皇帝，成为了全不列颠的皇帝。但是……但他的继承人们发现，他们
can't basically keep a hold on the northern reaches i mean not just of of britain full stop but of um you know the northern reaches of northumbria yeah um and so basically the scottish king starts to kind of annex them but it's all very incoherent it's inchoate it's not entirely clear what's what this is not in any way stable yeah and a crucial complication here which is a kind of gap in the sources and so it's quite hard it's like kind of looking for a black hole is the uppermost reaches of what had been Pictland so what is now kind of Inverness, Moray Forth that kind of region so it this had been a Pictish kingdom called fortry you right as if we need another kingdom and it re-emerges about 150 years later as the kingdom of moray and that's macbeth's kingdom
基本上无法守住北方的领地——不仅是大不列颠全境的北方，还有……你知道的，诺森布里亚北部的领地，是的。所以基本上苏格兰国王开始吞并它们。但这一切都非常不连贯，很不成熟，完全不清楚这到底是什么，这根本谈不上稳定。这里有一个至关重要的复杂之处，这是一个历史记载中的空白期，所以很难找，就像在寻找一个黑洞，那就是曾经的皮克特兰的最北端，也就是现在因弗内斯、莫里湾那样的地区。这是一个曾被称为福特里（Fortriu）的皮克特王国。没错，就好像我们需要另一个王国一样。大约150年后，它作为莫里王国重新出现，那就是麦克白的王国。
that is macbeth's kingdom okay so i can see macbeth at the end we're we're we're in a massive tunnel but i can just about make out at the end of it so so the two the two aspects of scotland when macbeth is born in about a thousand a.d yeah they have to be born in mind which are subsequently kind of overwritten and and reconfigured are firstly the kingdom of alba of scotland does not yet correspond to scotland as it is now because because the kingdom of moray it it's you know it's a co-kingdom it's a kind of sub-kingdom but it's not entirely absorbed into the kingdom of scotland and it's you know it's a co-kingdom it's a kind of sub-kingdom but it's not entirely absorbed into the kingdom of scotland and it's mainly in the highlands or yeah it's so it's around inverness
那是麦克白王国。好的，所以我终于在尽头看到麦克白了。我们身处一个巨大的隧道里，但我勉强能在尽头看到光亮。所以，当麦克白大约在公元1000年出生时，苏格兰的这两个方面，它们必须被铭记在心，它们后来被某种程度上重写和重新配置了：首先，麦克白出生时的阿尔巴王国、苏格兰王国，还不对应于现在的苏格兰，因为莫里王国……它是一个联合王国，它是一个次王国，但它并没有完全被吸收到苏格兰王国中。它主要在高地，或者……是的，它在因弗内斯附近，
yeah uh cordor yes so all these kind of places yeah um and the other thing is that the the line of succession from kenneth mcalpin is incredibly confusing and i'm aware that everything i've said up till now is confusing. So I'm hoping the listeners won't be running off howling, their eyeballs dropping out at all this. Or just asleep. But basically there is no single accepted line of succession from it. Because under Scottish law, Gaelic law,
还有卡多尔。所以所有这些地方。嗯，另一件事是，从肯尼思·麦克亚尔平开始的王位继承序列令人难以置信地混乱，我知道我刚才所说的一切都很混乱。所以我希望听众们不会吓得号啕大哭、眼珠子掉出来。或者只是睡着了。但基本上，从那以后并没有单一被普遍接受的继承序列。因为根据苏格兰法律、盖尔法律，
descendants of the great-grandfather can can inherit the throne so that means in effect that kenneth mccarpen had two sons so there are two lines of succession and they basically kind of alternate so there's no kind of primogeniture there is no are you elected by a group of nobles how's it work yeah basically right basically uh it's yes i mean if you're um you're if you're an atheling to put it in the kind of English terms yeah you are kind of worthy to to inherit and and that depends partly on whether you you know you have the right line of descent it's partly whether you're you're of military age it's partly your record it's partly your marriage it's partly how many kind of backers you have so so we have a question about this Tom yeah we can we can we can drag this back towards the questions that the listeners sent in
曾祖父的后代可以继承王位。这意味着实际上肯尼思·麦克亚尔平有两个儿子，所以有两个继承序列，它们基本上是交替的。所以这里没有长子继承制，没有长子继承制。你是被一群贵族选举产生的吗？它是怎么运作的？基本上，对。基本上，是的……如果你是一个阿瑟林（Atheling，盎格鲁-逊王室男性后裔），用英语的说法，是的，你有资格继承，这部分取决于你是否有正确的血统，部分取决于你是否到了服兵役的年龄，部分取决于你的履历，部分取决于你的婚姻，部分取决于你有多少支持者。所以我们对此有一个问题，汤姆。我们可以……我们可以把这个话题拉回到听众发来的问题上。
SHSK English says was it usual for Scottish kings to name their successors as Duncan names Malcolm? no right okay so it's not usual and this kind of plunges us into the key about what's happening with Macbeth Okay, so it's not usual. And this kind of plunges us into the key about what's happening with Macbeth and why he's such a significant figure for subsequent Scottish history.
SHSK English问：苏格兰国王像邓肯命名马尔科姆那样指定继承人，这很常见吗？不，好吧。所以这并不常见，这让我们直接切入了关于麦克白的关键事件。好吧，这并不常见。这让我们直接切入了关于麦克白以及为什么他对后来的苏格兰历史如此重要的核心。
Great, great. So early 11th century, the age of Cnut. Yes. Great, you know so england danish king england england's focus is kind of the north sea empire isn't it of canute and and all that stuff yes um 1005 yeah you have one of these classic events of early medieval scotland when kenneth the son of malcolm is killed by malcolm the son of kenneth so malcolm the son of kenneth becomes malcolm the second right um and he's the king of scotland yep he's he's a very effective player
太好了，太好了。11世纪初，克努特的时代。是的。伟大，你知道，所以英格兰、丹麦国王、英格兰的重心某种程度上是克努特的北海帝国，不是吗，以及所有那些东西。是的。公元1005年，发生了早期中世纪苏格兰的经典事件之一：马尔科姆的儿子肯尼思被肯尼思的儿子马尔科姆杀死，于是肯尼思的儿子马尔科姆成为了马尔科姆二世。没错。他是苏格兰国王。是的，他是一个非常有效的玩家。
but his first so the king of scotland this is not moray no he's the king of scotland so moray is still part we'll come to moray in a minute. But we need to get Malcolm II. So he's the King of the rest of Scotland? Yes, basically. Well, he's the King of Scotland because Moray is not yet a part of Scotland. Yeah, okay, fine. I mean, it is kind of complicated but you've just got to keep in your mind that
但他的第一任……所以苏格兰国王，这不是莫里，对吧？不，他是苏格兰国王。所以莫里仍然是一部分……我们一会儿会谈到莫里。但我们需要了解马尔科姆二世。所以他是苏格兰其余地区的国王？是的，基本上。好吧，他是苏格兰国王，因为莫里当时还不是苏格兰的一部分。是的，好吧，好吧。我的意思是，这有点复杂，但你只需要记住，
there is no Scotland. There is no United Scotland. Yes, it doesn't correspond to Scotland as it is now. So 1006, he attacks There is no United Scotland. There is no... Yes, it doesn't correspond to Scotland as it is now. Yeah. So 1006, he attacks Northumbria. Okay. I was dreading you were going to say Kenneth, the son of Malcolm. No, he attacks Northumbria and he gets defeated by...
没有一个统一的苏格兰。没有一个统一的苏格兰。是的，它不对应于现在的苏格兰。所以在1006年，他进攻……没有一个统一的苏格兰。没有一个……是的，它不对应于现在的苏格兰。是的。所以在1006年，他进攻诺森布里亚。好吧。我刚才还担心你会说是肯尼思，马尔科姆的儿子。不，他进攻诺森布里亚，然后他被……
I think it's the son or the nephew of the Northumbrian Earl. And do you know what he's called? Kenneth. No, he's called Uhtred. Oh, Uhtred. Very nice. All fans of Bertrand Cornwall. Very good. and do you know what he's called kenneth no he's called utrid oh utrid very nice very good um and uh the scots get the scots army gets wiped out all the nobles get um they get um beheaded the heads get taken to the um the women of bambra who braid their hair
我记得是诺森布里亚伯爵的儿子或侄子击败的。你知道他叫什么名字吗？肯尼思。不，他叫乌特雷德。哦，乌特雷德。非常好。伯纳德·康威尔的所有粉丝。非常好。你知道他叫什么名字？肯尼思。不，他叫乌特雷德。哦，乌特雷德。非常好。非常好。嗯……苏格兰军队被全歼了，所有的贵族都被……被砍了头，头颅被带去给班堡的妇女，她们把头颅的头发编成辫子。
oh nice uh and then they're each woman who braids the hair of a severed head gets a cow for her work from Utrecht. And then they're stuck on spikes around Bamburgh and Durham. So this is a kind of great victory for Northumbrian arms. And it looks like Malcolm is, you know, he's a busted flush before he's even begun. Angela Rayner would say that's just how we do things in the North. Yes, yes. Well, yes, they're treated like scum.
哦，太棒了。然后每一个给被砍下的头颅编辫子的妇女都能从乌特雷德那里得到一头牛作为报酬。然后它们被插在班堡和达勒姆周边的尖桩上。所以这是诺森布里亚军队的一场巨大胜利。看起来马尔科姆在还没开始之前就已经是个失败者了。安吉拉·雷纳（Angela Rayner）会说，我们北方人做事就是这样。是的，是的。嗯，是的，他们被当成渣滓对待。
These poor Scottish nobles. But Malcolm is, he's a survivor and he's a canny player and he retrenches and he consolidates his power. And then in 1018, so kind of 15 years later, he invades again. And this time it's a smashing success. And this is the Battle of Carham, which effectively establishes that the River Tweed is the border between what will become Scotland and England. And the English lands of Lothian, which have been part of Northumbria, become a part of Scotland. And so this is all kind of happening on. Now, Malcolm wants to nail down his son has died, but his grandson is a guy called Duncan. We all know Duncan.
这些可怜的苏格兰贵族。但马尔科姆是一个幸存者，他是一个精明的棋手，他收缩防线并巩固了自己的权力。然后在1018年，也就是大约15年后，他再次入侵。这一次取得了巨大的成功。这就是卡勒姆战役（Battle of Carham），它有效地确立了特威德河（River Tweed）是未来苏格兰和英格兰之间的边界。而原本属于诺森布里亚的英格兰土地洛锡安，成为了苏格兰的一部分。所以这一切都在发生。现在，马尔科姆想要稳固……他的儿子已经去世了，但他的孙子是一个叫邓肯的家伙。我们都知道邓肯。
And Duncan, in turn, has two sons, Malcolm and Donald Bain. Okay, yes, this is all very familiar. So Malcolm wants to nail down Duncan as his heir, despite the fact that there are kind of alternative candidates. Yeah. heir despite the fact that there are kind of alternative candidates yeah and one of those candidates is the king of moray who is called macbeth finally okay so how old is macbeth at this point so um well so um malcolm dies in 1034 so macbeth he's probably born around a thousand so he's in his mid-30s um and he is so his grandfather was called Rory all right Rory so it's his grandfather Irish or Gaelic Gaelic Gaelic yeah yeah because they're all they're all starting to speak Gaelic by this point his father is called
而邓肯反过来有两个儿子，马尔科姆和唐纳德·贝恩。好的，是的，这一切都非常熟悉。所以马尔科姆想要确定邓肯为他的继承人，尽管还有其他候选人。是的。尽管还有其他候选人，是的。而其中一个候选人就是莫里国王，他叫麦克白。终于来了。好吧，此时麦克白多大年龄？嗯，所以……马尔科姆死于1034年，所以麦克白可能出生于1000年左右，所以他当时三十多岁。他是……所以他的外祖父叫罗里。好吧，罗里。所以他的外祖父是爱尔兰人还是盖尔人？盖尔人。盖尔人，是的，是的。因为到这个时候他们都开始说盖尔语了。他的父亲叫
Finlay he's a rather ineffectual guy who is, you know, he wants to, you know, he has ambitions to become more powerful than he is as king of Moray. But he's a bit ineffectual. Right. He gets murdered by his nephews. So Macbeth's cousins. Macbeth has to flee, probably to Ireland. Okay. Then Macbeth comes back. By this time one of it the elder of his
芬莱。他是一个相当无能的家伙，你知道的，他想要……你知道的，他有野心变得比作为莫里国王时更有权势。但他有点无能。没错。他被他的侄子们谋杀了。也就是麦克白的堂兄弟们。麦克白不得不逃跑，可能是逃往爱尔兰。然后麦克白回来了。当时他的一个……年长的
cousins has died but there's the younger one a guy called Giller Comgain so not Malcolm not Kenneth so this is an exciting development he gets burnt to death we don't know whether it's Macbeth who does it but perhaps it was okay I mean Macbeth stands to benefit and then Macbeth marries so Macbeth marries a woman who is a descendant of Kenneth McAlpine from the opposite line from the one that Malcolm II has come from so that gives him a bit of a bit of a claim right it does so he's now secure on the throne of Moray yeah and he's married this woman yeah who becomes Lady Maceth. And do you know her name? Sheila. Gruwok.
堂兄已经去世了，但还有一个年幼的，一个叫吉勒·康根（Giller Comgain）的家伙。所以不是马尔科姆，也不是肯尼思。这是一个令人兴奋的发展。他被活活烧死了。我们不知道是不是麦克白干的，但也许是的。好吧，我的意思是麦克白从中获益了。然后麦克白结婚了……所以麦克白娶了一个女人，她是肯尼思·麦克亚尔平的后代，来自与马尔科姆二世不同的另一个血统支系，这给了他一点点王位继承权，对吧？确实如此。所以他现在稳坐莫里王位，是的，而且他娶了这个女人，是的，她成为了麦克白夫人。你知道她的名字吗？希拉。格鲁奥克。
Gruwok. Okay. Gruwok. And she has a son, Lulak. So what language is this? This is Gaelic. Okay, that's Gaelic as well. So there's always, from the play, there's always this famous question.
格鲁奥克。好的，格鲁奥克。她有一个儿子，卢拉克（Lulak）。那这是什么语言？这是盖尔语。好的，这也是盖尔语。所以剧里一直有一个著名的问题。
How many children did Lady Macbeth have? Yeah. Because she describes having babies, but then she says she has no you know yes they have no children yeah but actually they have one they have this this lulok lulok lulok lady macbeth does so he this becomes macbeth's foster son so macbeth is an obvious candidate for those who are opposed to duncan yeah and duncan unlike Duncan, unlike in Shakespeare's play, is not a kind of wise old guy with a long white beard. He's a rather rash, hot-tempered guy, again, in his mid-30s, same age pretty much as Macbeth.
麦克白夫人到底生了几个孩子？是的。因为她描述过自己生过婴儿，但后来她说她没有……是的，他们没有孩子。是的。但实际上他们有一个，他们有这个卢拉克，卢拉克，卢拉克，麦克白夫人生的。所以他成为了麦克白的养子。所以麦克白是那些反对邓肯的人的显然后选人，是的。而邓肯，
And he decides that he's going to launch a pre-emptive strike against Macbeth because he can see that that um Macbeth is consolidating his power in Moray uh Duncan doesn't really want a bit of this you know so he invades Macbeth goes out to meet him kills Duncan in battle and so Macbeth is then the only candidate to become king and becomes king so Macbeth has been very hard done by at this judging so far. I mean, he hasn't behaved badly at all. Well, apart from burning his uncle, his cousin to death, perhaps.
与莎士比亚戏剧中不同，他不是那种留着长长白胡子的睿智老人。他是个相当冲动、脾气暴躁的家伙，同样三十多岁，和麦克白差不多的年龄。他决定对麦克白发动先发制人的打击，因为他能看出麦克白正在莫里巩固自己的权力。邓肯其实并不想放过这一点，所以他入侵了。麦克白出兵迎战，在战斗中杀死了邓肯，于是麦克白成为了唯一的王位候选人并登基为王。所以麦克白在这方面受了很大的委屈。我的意思是，他表现得一点也不坏。好吧，除了可能把他的叔叔、堂兄活活烧死。
But that's the context of general bad behaviour, I would say. Yes, yes. I mean, that's kind of very much par for the course of what's going on. So he's not Richard III. He doesn't stand out to people at the time. No, not at all.
但这属于当时普遍的不良行为背景，我想是的。是的，是的。我的意思是，这非常符合当时普遍的情况。所以他不是理查三世。他在当时并没有给人们留下这样的印象。不，一点也不。
As tyrannical. Absolutely not. No, not at all. So then he's not toppled straight away. No, not at all. As tyrannical. Absolutely not. No, not at all. So then he's not toppled straight away. No, no, no. He's 14 years or something. No. So he becomes king in 1040.
作为一个暴君。绝对没有。不，一点也没有。所以他并没有立刻被推翻。不，不，不。他统治了14年左右。不。所以他在1040年成为国王。
Yeah. And Duncan's sons, Malcolm and Donald Bain, flee, as they do in the play. In the play, they go to England. Probably they go to Orkney, which is a kind of further complicating factor because orkney is norse is viking okay so that's a kind of further yeah you know let's not get into the game yeah no we won't we won't and macbeth um rules very very successfully and so you know i said he goes to rome so he and grew up go to r Rome and they kind of issue charters handing out their land and things before they go. And, you know, this is the oldest named chart.
是的。邓肯的儿子们马尔科姆和唐纳德·贝恩逃跑了，就像剧里演的那样。在剧中，他们去了英格兰。可能他们去了奥克尼，这是一个进一步复杂的因素，因为奥克尼是诺斯的，是维京人的。好的，所以那是一个进一步的……是的，你知道的，我们不要扯进那个游戏里。是的，不，我们不会的。麦克白统治得非常非常成功。所以，我刚才说他去了罗马，所以他和格鲁奥克去了罗马，在他们出发前，他们发布了宪章，分发土地之类的事情。而且，你知道，这是有记载的
This is the oldest charter naming a queen of Scotland. It's Lady Macbeth. I mean, it's kind of amazing. It is amazing. Yeah, it's absolutely brilliant. So he so he could not have gone to on pilgrimage to Rome. And he could do that because he was a great and famous king, incredibly powerful. Yeah.
以女王名义发布的最古老的宪章。这就是麦克白夫人。我的意思是，这真是太惊人了。这确实惊人。是的，绝对太棒了。所以他……所以他不可能去罗马朝圣。他能做到这一点，是因为他是一位伟大而著名的国王，权力极其强大。是的。
Nobody, you know, was going to challenge his authority while he was away. So the fact that Macbeth can do the same is a tribute to, you know, how firmly rooted. Does no revolt or anything like that? Yes, absolutely. So this is kind of basically, he's establishing an entire new dynasty. Yeah. The dynasty of Moray. Basically, the dynasty of Kenneth McAlpine has been parked
没有人敢在他不在的时候挑战他的权威。所以麦克白能做到这一点，这证明了……你知道的，他的统治根基有多么牢固。没有发生叛乱或类似的事情吗？是的，绝对没有。所以这基本上是……他正在建立一个全新的王朝。是的。莫里王朝。基本上，肯尼思·麦克亚尔平的王朝被搁置了，
and you could see that, you know, if they'd had children, if Lulac in turn had his children, that this would set Scotland
你可以看到，如果他们有孩子的话，如果卢拉克反过来也有自己的孩子，这将使苏格兰
on a kind of completely new dynastic course. Yeah. However, that is not what happens. Do we have time? Will you get through this
走上一条完全崭新的王朝道路。是的。然而，事情并非如此。我们还有时间吗？你能在中场休息前讲完吗？
before the break? Yes, I will. How much time have I got? I don't know, you've got a few minutes. Okay, this is very Rachel Morley. So, 1054, the English invade again. So it was the English, wasn't it? Well, it isn't always, because actually the English haven't been invading very much.
是的，我会的。我还有多少时间？我不知道，你还有几分钟。好吧，这很有雷切尔·莫利的风格。所以，1054年，英格兰人再次入侵。所以是英格兰人，对吧？嗯，也不总是这样，因为实际上英格兰人并没有经常入侵。
So this is the first invasion since Athelstan's invasion, about 100 years, you know, over 100 years before. Yeah. And it's not entirely an English invasion because by this point, the Earl of Northumbria is a Scandinavian, Earl Seward. Right, yes, yes.
所以这是自埃塞尔斯坦入侵以来，大约100年（也就是100年多以前）以来的第一次入侵。是的。而且这并不完全是一次英格兰人的入侵，因为到这个时候，诺森布里亚伯爵是一个斯堪的纳维亚人，西华德伯爵（Earl Siward）。没错，是的，是的。
And he's married Uhtred's granddaughter. And basically he's invading Scotland just for the fun of it because he's a Scandinavian warlord and because he can. So he goes and he crosses the Firth of Forth, struck up into the highlands. Macbeth, it seems, was aiming for a hill fort called Dunsinane.
他娶了乌特雷德的孙女。基本上他入侵苏格兰只是为了好玩，因为他是一个斯堪的纳维亚军阀，而且他有这个能力。所以他去了，渡过了福斯湾，一路打进高地。麦克白似乎是想去一个叫邓西纳（Dunsinane）的山地堡垒。
But he doesn't fight there. He gets kind of cornered. And there's an incredibly brutal battle on the feast day of the seven sleepers of Ephesus. Christians who went to sleep during persecution and wake up a century later and everything's great so this is known as the battle of the seven sleepers Macbeth ends up losing so he has to kind of flee but Seward it's bad for him too because his son and heir dies in the battle which again is kind of mentioned in the play yes but but unlike
但他没有在那里开战。他被逼入绝境。在以弗所七隐士的节日那天，爆发了一场极其残酷的战役。基督徒在迫害期间入睡并在一个世纪后醒来，一切都变得美好。所以这被称为七隐士之战。麦克白最终落败，所以他不得不逃跑。但对西华德来说这也是个坏消息，因为他的儿子兼继承人在战斗中丧生了，这也是剧里提到的。是的，但是与
in the play Macbeth is not finished you know he's able to kind of fight on because he is kind of mentioned in the play yes but but unlike in the play Macbeth is not finished you know he's able to kind of fight on because he's kind of doing the classic guerrilla tactics of retreating up into the highlands that you know people have always done in Scotland and the following year Seward dies of dysentery which is a kind of bad way for a viking warlord to go occupational hazard when you're leading armies in um medieval period but things but but obviously macbeth's prestige and stability of his his reign have been severely knocked yeah and so uh he has you know this kind of threatening figure of malcolm the son of duncan hovering in the background who's in alliance with the with the nor Orkney. And the Norse of Orkney attack in 1057, and Lulac is slain.
剧中的情况不同，麦克白并没有完蛋。你知道，他能够继续战斗，因为……剧里确实提到了这一点，是的。但是与剧中的情况不同，麦克白并没有完蛋。你知道，他能够继续战下去，因为他一直在进行那种退守到高地的经典游击战术，苏格兰人一直以来都在这么做。第二年，西华德死于痢疾，对于一个维京军阀来说，这算是一种糟糕的死法，在中世纪率领军队时这也是一种职业风险。但显然，麦克白的威望和统治的稳定性受到了沉重打击，是的。所以……他身边有一个挥之不去的威胁性人物——邓肯的儿子马尔科姆，他与奥克尼的诺斯人结成了同盟。奥克尼的诺斯人在1057年发动了进攻，卢拉克被杀。
Actually, by this point, Macbeth has retired and gone to a monastery. Oh, right. So Lulac is kind of, yes, yes. So Lulac is kind of ready to become king, but gets killed, I think, treacherously. The implication is in kind of, you know, he goes to negotiations and gets stabbed,
实际上，到这个时候，麦克白已经退位并进入了一座修道院。哦，原来如此。所以卢拉克某种程度上……是的，是的。所以卢拉克准备成为国王，但被杀了，我认为是遭到了背叛。暗示是在……你知道的，他去谈判时被刺杀了，
kind of very Game of Thrones style. to negotiations and gets stabbed. Yeah. Kind of very Game of Thrones style. Yeah. So Macbeth comes out of retirement, meets with Malcolm and is defeated and Malcolm becomes king. But again, it's the measure of the respect in which Macbeth is held that,
非常有《权力的游戏》风格。去谈判时被刺杀了。是的。非常有《权力的游戏》风格。是的。所以麦克白复出，与马尔科姆会面并被击败，马尔科姆成为了国王。但同样，这衡量了人们对麦克白的尊重程度：
unlike in the play where, you know, Macbeth's body and that of Lady Macbeth are exposed to kind of be a wonder and a horror to the Scots, Macbeth is given a very honourable burial on the Isle of Iona, which is the traditional burial place for the Kings of Scotland.
不像剧中所描绘的那样，麦克白和麦克白夫人的尸体被暴露出来，供苏格兰人惊叹和惊恐，麦克白在爱奥那岛（Isle of Iona）得到了非常体面的安葬，那是苏格兰国王的传统安葬地。
So he's laid to rest there. But obviously his, you know, his dynasty is finished and the dynasty of Kenneth MacAlpine has returned to the throne. And this essentially establishes the kind of the myth that Kenneth McAlpine was the undisputed founder of Scottish royalty and that there is this continuous line that can be traced. And that Macbeth is a usurper.
所以他在那里长眠。但显而易见，他的……他的王朝结束了，肯尼思·麦克亚尔平的王朝重返王位。这基本上确立了这样一种神话：肯尼思·麦克亚尔平是苏格兰王室无可争议的创始者，并且存在一条可以追溯的连续血统。而麦克白是一个篡位者。
And this obviously becomes incredibly important during the 13th and 14th century in the war with England, when England is trying to annex the Scottish kingdom. Because the kings of Scotland need to assert the fact that they have a kind of a lineage that is as straight and clear and distinguished as the English one yeah and Macbeth simply doesn't fit into this story so he has to be cast as a usurper great so Macbeth has lived and died that was the real Macbeth and now we'll take a break and then the second half the three witches all that kind of stuff. So we'll see you after the break. and on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
这在13世纪和14世纪与英格兰的战争中变得极其重要，当时英格兰正试图吞并苏格兰王国。因为苏格兰国王需要宣称他们拥有像英格兰人那样直接、清晰、尊贵的血统，是的，而麦克白根本不符合这个故事，所以他必须被塑造成一个篡位者。太好了，麦克白生平讲完了，这就是真实的麦克白。现在我们要休息一下，下半场讲三位女巫，诸如此类的内容。我们休息后见。以及娱乐节目，我们将告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告音频、加更节目和抢先获得现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. A drum, a drum, the rest is history. The second part doth come. That's terrible, isn't it? That's absolutely shocker. That's great. I think you should do that every time. Yes.
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。鼓啊鼓，历史的余烬。第二部分来啦。这太糟糕了吧？这绝对是个震撼弹。太棒了。我觉得你每次都该这么干。是的。
So we're talking about Macbeth. In the first half, we've plunged into the absolute bog that is early medieval Scotland. And we've now dragged ourselves out of that bog. Well, you were in that bog. Yeah, I was in that bog. You were just kind of watching, offering questions scoffers laughing laughing um so basically we've we've established the reason why um macbeth is kind of transformed into this figure of a usurper yes um and uh by the 16th century when ralph hollinshead the great chronicler not just of
我们在谈论麦克白。在上半场中，我们深入探讨了早期中世纪苏格兰那片绝对的泥潭。现在我们把自己从泥潭里拉出来了。好吧，是你陷在泥潭里。是的，我陷在那个泥潭里。你只是在旁边看着，提出问题，嘲笑，大笑。所以基本上，我们已经确立了……为什么……麦克白会被塑造成一个篡位者的形象的原因。是的。而且……
england but of scotland and ireland is doing his his chronicle um macbeth the story of macbeth with the the three weird sisters and banquo and macduff and all that kind of stuff it's it's there as history yes um and dominic we we have a question here uh from barry grogan if james the first of eng, the sixth of Scotland, wasn't king, would Shakespeare have ever written Macbeth? It appears to be somewhat of a Scottish story for the newish Scottish king of England. So what is the context for Shakespeare
到了16世纪，当伟大的编年史家拉斐尔·霍林谢德（Raphael Holinshed，他不单记载英格兰，还记载苏格兰和爱尔兰）编写他的编年史时，麦克白的故事——带着三个怪异的姐妹、班考、麦克达夫以及所有这些东西——已经作为历史存在了。是的。多米尼克，我们这里有一个问题，来自巴里·格罗根（Barry Grogan）：“如果英格兰的一世、苏格兰的六世詹姆斯没有成为国王，莎士比亚还会写出《麦克白》吗？这似乎在某种程度上是一个为英格兰这位新苏格兰国王量身定制的苏格兰故事。”那么，莎士比亚决定挑选霍林谢德编年史中发现的这个故事并继续发挥下去，其背景是什么？嗯，我认为——我不知道你是否会不同意这一点——但我认为，如果不是詹姆斯成为国王，他绝对不可能写出《麦克白》。我的意思是，也许有极其微小的可能，但它显然是为一位新的斯图尔特国王而写的。为了交代一下背景，伊丽莎白一世于1603年去世，苏格兰的詹姆斯六世成为了同时统治英格兰的第一位苏格兰国王。所以这就有一种……英苏关系的话题弥漫在空气中。
deciding to pick up on this story that he's found in Holland's Chronicle and running with it? Well, I think, I don't know whether you'll disagree with this or not, but I think there's no possibility he would have written Macbeth had it not been for James becoming king. I mean, I suppose there's an outside possibility, but it's deliberately written for a new Stuart king. So to give the context here, Elizabeth I has died in 1603 and James VI of Scotland has become the first Scottish king to rule England as well. So there's this sort of... The Anglo-Scottish stuff is in the ether.
决定选用他在霍林舍德的编年史中发现的这个故事并将其展开？嗯，我认为，我不知道你会不会不同意这一点，但我认为如果不是詹姆斯成为国王，他绝对不可能写出《麦克白》。我的意思是，我想存在一种微乎其微的可能性，但它确实是特意为一位新的斯图尔特国王而写的。为了交代一下背景，伊丽莎白一世于1603年去世，苏格兰的詹姆斯六世成为第一位同时统治英格兰的苏格兰国王。所以这就有点……英苏关系的种种充斥在空气中。
There's a lot of anxiety. It's an incredibly paranoid time anyway, as everybody knows, you know, fears of plots and so on. Now, the Gunpowder Plot plays a huge part... Yes, so Macbeth is written and comes out in 1606. That's when we think it was first performed. So I don't want to go down yet another rabbit hole. OK, and the gunpowder plot is yet another okay but the gunpowder plot is 1605 yes so it's absolutely written in the shadow of that
有很多焦虑。正如每个人都知道的那样，这是一个非常偏执的时期，你知道，人们害怕阴谋等等。现在，“火药阴谋”起到了巨大的作用……是的，所以《麦克白》在1606年写成并问世。那是我们认为它首次演出的时候。所以我不想再掉进另一个兔子洞了。好吧，“火药阴谋”又是另一个——好吧，但是“火药阴谋”发生在1605年，是的，所以它绝对是在那个阴影下创作的
so that's what we think so basically Shakespeare and his company they end up becoming the king's men they have the patronage of James which obviously you want if you're a theatrical company company um james believes that he is descended from banquo so banquo is in the the holland's head chronicles in 1577 but he's macbeth's collaborator so shakespeare changes banquo's character so banquo becomes the voice of virtue you know horrified by macbeth's crimes the ghost of the feast and all that stuff and And Fleeance's son escapes. Exactly. To become the forefather of Mary, Queen of Scots and James. Precisely.
所以这就是我们的想法，基本上莎士比亚和他的剧团最终成为了“国王剧团”，他们得到了詹姆士的赞助，如果你是一个戏剧剧团，你显然希望得到这种赞助，嗯……詹姆士相信他是班柯的后代，所以班柯出现在1577年的《霍林舍德编年史》中，但他却是麦克白的同谋，所以莎士比亚改变了班柯的角色，于是班柯成了美德的化身，你知道的，对麦克白的罪行感到震惊，他是宴会上的鬼魂诸如此类。而弗里昂斯的儿子逃脱了。没错。成为了苏格兰女王玛丽和詹姆士的先祖。正是如此。
So it's a bit of, it's clearly flattering James in that sense. The gunpowder plot stuff is absolutely fascinating. So this is what helps us to date it because Shakespearean historians have sort of, you know, it's all very unclear with Shakespeare. When some plays were written, who wrote, you know, Shakespeare and a collaborator or what um and when they were performed but we are pretty sure that this is written and performed after the gunpowder plot because there is a whole scene in which the porter who is there for comic relief gives this speech in
所以这在某种程度上显然是在奉承詹姆士。关于“火药阴谋”的事情绝对令人着迷。所以这就是帮助我们确定创作时间的原因，因为莎士比亚的历史学家们有点——你知道的，关于莎士比亚的一切都非常不明确。有些剧本是什么时候写的，是谁写的（你知道的，莎士比亚和一个合作者，或者其他什么），以及它们是什么时候演出的，但我们非常确定这部剧是在“火药阴谋”之后创作并演出的，因为里面有一整场戏，负责调节喜剧气氛的看门人在发表这样一段演讲：
which he is mocking basically the speech that a Jesuituit called henry garnett gave at his trial after the gunpowder plot so garnett relied upon a defense called equivocation you'll know much more about me than well he writes the pamphlet but he writes the pamphlet about it doesn't he and and and um uh james again remind me what it is it's a well doctrine of so equivocation up until 1605 basically means something that's ambiguous yeah so it's you know it's it's something that could be one thing or the other but after this pamphlet is found and and um garnett is the uh i mean he's the kind of jesuit superior in england so he's top jesuit uh and he he he was very against the gunpowder plot but he'd been told about it but he'd'd been told about it under the law of confession.
他在演讲中基本上是在嘲讽一个名叫亨利·加内特的耶稣会士在“火药阴谋”审判后发表的演讲，所以加内特依靠的是一种名为“模棱两可”的辩护，你们对它的了解可能比我多得多——好吧，他写了关于这件事的小册子，不是吗？还有……呃，詹姆士，再次提醒我那是什么？这是一个关于……的理论。所以“模棱两可”在1605年之前基本上是指模棱两可的事物，是的，所以它你知道的，它是那种可能既是这样又是那样的事物，但在发现这本小册子之后，而且……呃，加内特是——我的意思是他是英国耶稣会的高级神长，所以他是顶级耶稣会士，并且他——他非常反对“火药阴谋”，但他事先知道了这件事，但他是在听告解的保密法律下得知这一点的。
He couldn't reveal it. But he kind of writes to his superiors in Rome and says, please do what you can, pull strings to try and stop this from going ahead. But it does go ahead. And so obviously he is absolutely in the firing line. So he gets arrested. And the agents who arrest him discover this pamphlet in which he's written
他无法透露。但他某种程度上写信给他在罗马的上级，说请尽你们所能，动用人脉试图阻止这件事继续下去。但这件事还是发生了。所以很明显，他完全成了众矢之的。于是他被捕了。逮捕他的特工们发现了这本小册子，他在里面写了
about equivocation being justified um and and and the the way that garnett uses equivocation is basically that you say one thing meaning the other so that you you won't get in trouble for catholics so it's a way for catholics to practice their faith without kind of drawing attention to themselves but this is incredibly controversial. Everybody mocks it and says this is terrible, weasley behaviour. And he gets executed. He gets executed.
关于模棱两可的辩解是正当的，嗯……并且加内特使用模棱两可的方式基本上就是你说一件事却指另一件事，这样天主教徒就不会惹上麻烦，所以这是天主教徒在不引起人们注意的情况下践行信仰的一种方式，但这极其具有争议性。所有人都嘲笑它，说这是可怕的、滑头的行为。然后他被处决了。他被处决了。
And so we know I think he's executed or he uses the equivocation defence, saying one thing and thinking another or whatever, in March 1606. And then the porter's speech in the play the porter was mocking equivocation I think or talking about it so Faith here's an equivocator that could swear
所以我们知道——我想他是被处决的，或者他使用了模棱两可的辩护，说一套做一套什么的，是在1606年3月。然后剧中的看门人的演讲——看门人在嘲讽模棱两可，我想，或者在谈论它——“信不信由你，这里有个模棱两可的人，他能在两边的天平上都发誓，
in both the scales against either scale who committed treason enough for God's sake yet could not equivocate in heaven so basically everybody thinks right 1606 it must be done in reaction to that because it's in the air. But generally, obviously, you've had the gunpowder plot, the attempt to kill the king.
对抗任何一边，他犯下的叛国罪足以让上帝发怒，然而却无法在天堂里模棱两可。”所以基本上所有人都想，对啊，1606年，它一定是对那件事的反应，因为它正弥漫在空气中。但总的来说，显而易见，之前发生了“火药阴谋”，也就是谋杀国王的企图。
You know, Macbeth is a play about killing a king. So it's kind of there. And it's in the context of there have been gazillions of plots against Elizabeth I and against James in Scotland and again in England. So it sort of feels very timely. And of course, there's one other element, which we'll probably come to now. Yeah, so we've got John Liddle. Is the role of witchcraft in Macbeth reflective of contemporaneous beliefs
你知道，《麦克白》就是一部关于谋杀国王的戏剧。所以这个主题是现成的。而且它的背景是，针对伊丽莎白一世、针对苏格兰的詹姆士以及再次针对英格兰的詹姆士，已经发生了无数次的阴谋。所以它感觉非常合时宜。当然，还有另一个因素，我们接下来可能会讲到。是的，所以我们有约翰·利德尔。《麦克白》中的巫术角色是反映了当时的信仰，
or is a Shakespearean era addition? So I guess by that, I mean, you know, is it something that comes from the 11th century? Let's not go back to the 11th century. But no, it's fine, Dominic, because it isn't. Because it's absolutely expressive of the witch craze, but specifically of James. So James, such a strange thing.
还是莎士比亚时代的添加？所以我想我的意思是，你知道的，这是源自11世纪的东西吗？我们别回到11世纪去了。不过没关系，多米尼克，因为事实并非如此。因为它绝对是疯狂迷信巫术的体现，但具体来说是针对詹姆士的。所以詹姆士，真是个奇怪的人。
We talked about James I in this podcast before. A fancy for courtiers with long legs, tongue too big for his mouth, slobbering, wisest fool in Christendom, all of this stuff. But the weirdest thing about him, I think, is this obsession with with witches so he writes a thing called demonology 1597 where he talks about demons
我们以前在这个播客里谈论过詹姆士一世。喜欢长腿的朝臣，舌头大得塞不进嘴里，流口水，全基督教世界最聪明的傻瓜，诸如此类。但关于他最奇怪的事情，我认为，就是他对女巫的这种痴迷，所以他写了一本名为《魔鬼学》（1597年）的书，里面谈到了恶魔、
vampires werewolves and witches above all and you know why you I'm sure you do know because he believes he's he's been targeted by witches so this really weird thing he sailed over to copenhagen to get anne of denmark his wife and it was very stormy and when he got there there was all these storms and the danes said oh this is undoubtedly the work of witches because the danes are obsessed with witches too the great trier witch trials in germany were taking place so the danes had heard about this they're very excited about witches james who's clearly a bit of a you know james loves a conspiracy theory and he's just interested in the occult and all this kind of stuff he says oh yes i probably have have been the target of of witches he gets back and um they have all these witch trials the north berwick witch trials and he's trying to round up now what's
吸毒鬼、狼人，最重要的是女巫，而且你知道为什么吗？我相信你一定知道，因为他认为自己成为了女巫的目标。所以这是一件非常奇怪的事情：他乘船去哥本哈根迎娶丹麦的安妮（他的妻子），当时风浪很大，等他到了那里，到处都是暴风雨，丹麦人说：“哦，这毫无疑问是女巫的干杰，”因为丹麦人也对女巫着迷，德国正举行盛大的审判女巫案，所以丹麦人对此早有耳闻，他们对女巫非常兴奋。詹姆士显然是个有点——你知道的，詹姆士喜欢阴谋论，而且他对神秘学这类东西很感兴趣，他说：“哦，是的，我可能一直是女巫的目标。”他回到英国后，嗯……他们举行了所有的审判女巫案，即诺北里克审判女巫案，他试图追捕——现在不清楚的是，他非常希望人们发现博思韦尔伯爵三世是首席女巫并正在策划这一切，因为博思韦尔伯爵是他的死敌，一直在密谋反对他。所以他们不断地审问这些妇女，说：“你们是不是一直在与博思韦尔伯爵和撒旦勾结，并密谋反对我？”
unclear is he really wants people to find that the third Earl of Bothwell is chief witch and is orchestrating this because the Earl of Bothwell is his great enemy and has been plotting against him. So they're constantly kind of interrogating his women and saying, have you been consorting with the Earl of Bothwell and Satan and plotting against me?
所以所有这些妇女，许多人都被杀害了。这是一个可怕的故事。詹姆士在这本名为《魔鬼学》的书里进行了详尽的论述。而在《魔鬼学》中，他谈到了审判女巫案。所以真正令人着迷的是，詹姆士显然
So all these women, lots of people are killed. It's a terrible story. And James writes at length in this book, Demonology. And in Demonology, it talks about the witch trials. So the really fascinating thing is that James is obviously
完全痴迷于阴谋论和密谋，这是可以理解的，因为他曾是这些阴谋的图谋目标。他痴迷于女巫。而莎士比亚从詹姆士自己的书中取材，并将其放进了戏剧中。他确实这么做了，但为了让故事稍微复杂一点，嗯……
completely obsessed with conspiracism plots, understandably, because he's been the attempted target of them. He's obsessed with witches. And Shakespeare takes some of the stuff from James's own book and puts it in the play he does but just just to complicate the story somewhat um
1605年8月——所以如果《麦克白》是在1606年写的，是的，大约前一年，伦敦爆发了瘟疫，是的，所以实行了封城，詹姆士去了牛津躲避瘟疫。当他骑马进入牛津时，遇到了三个扮成仙女的年轻男子。这三个年轻男子用拉丁语向他欢呼，大意是：“万岁，苏格兰的詹姆士！万岁，大不列颠的国王詹姆士！”等等，嗯……这是由一个名叫马修·格温的人写的，他是一个颇有学问的剧作家，这些内容取自《霍林舍德》，他采用了——在《霍林舍德》中，向麦克白欢呼的那三个女人并不叫女巫，这很有趣，所以她们被称为——我想是“奇异的女人”，是的，诸如此类，所以人们显然认为
august 1605 so if macbeth is written in 1606 yeah kind of year before there's plague in london yeah so there's a lockdown um and james goes goes to Oxford to sit out the plague. And as he rides into Oxford, he's met by three young men dressed as nymphs. And these three young men in Latin hail him kind of along the lines of, you know, hail James of scotland hail james king of great britain and so on um and this is written by a guy called matthew gwynn who's who's a kind of very scholarly playwright who's taken it from holland's head and he's taken the the uh they're not called witches in holland's head the three women who who hail macbeth um it's interesting so he they're called i think weird women yeah that kind of thing um and so people have obviously kind of thought
好吧，你知道的，这是——这是一个影响吗？几乎可以肯定，我的意思是，看起来不可能不是这样的——我的意思是，你知道的，莎士比亚可能……莎士比亚怎么会知道这件事呢？好吧，他当时不在伦敦，所以也许他当时也在牛津。我们不知道。我的意思是，你知道的，他是“国王剧团”的成员。或者也许他听说过。此时这三个仙女的出现是写好的剧本，这是一场盛大的公开……是的，所以这是一场盛大的公开假面舞会。
well you know is this is this an influence and almost certainly i mean it seemed it seems impossible that it wasn't um i mean, you know, Shakespeare might have... How would Shakespeare know about it? Well, so he's not in London at the time, so maybe he was in Oxford as well. We don't know. I mean, you know, he's King's Men. Or maybe he heard about it. At this moment with the three nymphs, this has been scripted and it's kind of a big public... Yeah, so it's a big kind of public mask.
所以莎士比亚当时可能在看，是的，观看。所以他可能看到了。我的意思是，我认为大家的共识是他不在场，但他显然会听说过。如果他在研究《麦克白》，那么他绝对会听说过。如果他看到詹姆士喜欢这个，他就会觉得应该把它写进去。但显然那三个奇异的修女
So Shakespeare could have been, yeah, watching. Yeah, so he could have watched it. I mean, I think the consensus is that he wasn't there, but he would obviously have heard about it. And if he's researching Macbeth, then definitely he would have heard about it. And if he'd seen that James loved this, then he'd think he'd put it in. But obviously the three weird sisters
要更具威胁性和危险性。好吧，她们是模棱两可的。我的意思是，她们模棱两可。你知道，麦克白谈到了那个模棱两可的恶魔。我认为，这也是反映“火药阴谋”的一点，当时新教英格兰的人们绝对有一种感觉，即这是魔鬼的干杰，因此策划谋杀国王的过程——你知道的，它一定源于——你知道的，人类本性的邪恶，也就是
are much more menacing and dangerous. Well, they're equivocal. I mean, they're equivocate. You know, Macbeth talks about the equivocating fiend. And I think that one of the things that also reflects that the gunpowder plot is the sense that the people in Protestant England absolutely have was that this was the work of the devil and that therefore kind of the the process of plotting against the king you know it must come from kind of you know the evil of human nature which is
麦克白和麦克白夫人，但它不知何故也源于某种比纯粹的人性更加邪恶、更加来自地狱的黑暗，这就是——我的意思是，这就是这部剧的精髓，不是吗？它是个人邪恶的融合，是的，还有某种超自然的黑暗。但它算是一种个人邪恶吗？你知道，莎士比亚创作这部剧的时间大约与《安东尼与克莉奥佩特拉》差不多（前后差了一年左右），而且有一种类似的——你知道的，《安东尼与克莉奥佩特拉》很大程度上取材自普鲁塔克，安东尼和克莉奥佩特拉身上有一种崇高感，但最终却悲剧性地毁了，他们的野心把他们引向歧途之类的。《麦克白》和麦克白夫人身上也有这种成分，是的，他们并非纯粹的邪恶，不，他们不是。但那就是悲剧所在，不是吗？麦克白是一个伟大的人物，他——是的——赢得了一场伟大的战役，并被授予了——
Macbeth and Lady Macbeth but it also somehow comes from a kind of darkness that is more hellish and more infernal than just human nature and that's kind of I mean that that's the essence of the play isn't it it's the fusion of personal evil yeah and a kind of supernatural darkness but is it kind of personal evil though you know Shakespeare was writing this at about the same time i mean give or take a year as anthony and cleopatra and and there's a similar kind of you know anthony and cleopatra gets a lot of that from plutarch there's a kind of nobility to anthony and cleopatra that is undone tragically their ambition leads them astray and stuff there's a bit of that in macbeth and lady macbeth yeah they're not pure evil no they're not but that's but that's the tragedy isn't it that macbeth is a kind of great man who's yeah who's who's won a great battle and who is given you
你知道，各种头衔，嗯……而麦克白夫人显然是一个非常强大的人物，是的，一个伟大的女主人，是的，对，我不能——你知道的，绝妙的聚会，还有什么比住在那里更有趣的呢？但他们迈出了这一步，从那一刻起，一切就开始走下坡路了——我的意思是，他们——这就是这部剧精髓所在。事实上，非常引人入胜的是，《麦克白》非常短，所以《麦克白》的篇幅大概只有《哈姆雷特》的一半，我想，嗯……一些莎士比亚学者说，你知道，按照莎士比亚的标准，《麦克白》和麦克白夫人在思想向行动的转变上非常快，而且他们的动机并非总是完全清晰，一些莎士比亚学者认为我们现有的文本是原始《麦克白》的一个残篇，
know all kinds of titles um and lady mcbeth is clearly a kind of very powerful figure yeah great hostess yes right well i can't you know brilliant clams what could be more fun than staying there but but they they take this step and from that point on it's it's downward i mean they that's the essence of the what is fascinating actually macbeth is very short so my breath is about half as long as hamlet i think and um some shakespearean scholars say you know macbeth and lady macbeth leaked by shakespearean standards very quickly from thought to deed and their motivation is not always entirely clear and some shakespearean scholars think that the text that we have is a fragment of the original
我们现在拥有的基本上是一个提示剧本——也就是说，一个在演员们周围流传但并非决定性的剧本（就莎士比亚曾经创作过决定性文本而言），但其实还有一个更宏大的《麦克白》，存在着某种“原始《麦克白》”（Ur-Macbeth），其中麦克白和麦克白夫人的性格塑造得更丰满。学习GCSE英语的学生一定会感到非常宽慰。他们一定会的，是的，我想这是真的。但是，当然，我的意思是，你知道，不管这是不是真的，这是一部变得如此著名的戏剧。
macbeth and that what we have basically is a prompt script so a script that was sort of hanging around um for the actors but is not the definitive i mean as insofar as shakespeare ever did definitive texts but there is a bigger macbeth there there is a kind of Ur-Macbeth, in which the characters of Macbeth and Lady Macbeth are more fleshed out. People doing GCSE English must be quite relieved. They must be, yes, I suppose that's true. But, of course, I mean, you know, whether that's true or not, it's a play that becomes so famous.
你知道谁是《麦克白》的超级粉丝吗？谁？塞缪尔·佩皮斯。我不知道这一点。佩皮斯在他的日记里提到去看这部戏。我想他大约去了十几次。他经常只是说：“你知道的，我又去看《麦克白》了。”
You know who's a big fan of Macbeth? Who? Samuel Pepys. I didn't know that. Pepys, in his diaries, goes to see it. I think he goes about a dozen times. He'll often just say, you know, I went again to see Macbeth.
太棒了。爱看。你认为吸引力在哪里？好吧，《麦克白》的吸引力是什么？我的意思是，《麦克白》的吸引力在于，对于一部莎士比亚戏剧来说，它的动作戏非常多。我认为超自然元素绝对是其中的一部分。谋杀国王的想法显然很吸引人，特别是——我的意思是，我们生活在一个——你知道的，我们本来就生活在一个暗杀盛行的时代，他们也是。是的。谋杀的概念——好吧，他们在舞台上并没有展示邓肯的死亡。
Brilliant. Loved it. What do you think the appeal was? Well, what is the appeal of Macbeth? I mean, the appeal of Macbeth is it's very action heavy for a Shakespearean play. I think the supernatural is absolutely part of it. The idea of killing a king is obviously fascinating, particularly, I mean, we live in an age of, you know, we live in an age of assassinations anyway, as did they. Yes. The idea of killing... Well, so they don't show the death of Duncan on stage.
是的。这很不寻常，可能很能反映当时的敏感性。是的，我确信。在舞台上展示一个苏格兰国王被谋杀。我确信。
Yeah. Which is unusual and may well, I guess, reflect sensitivities. Yes, I'm sure. Showing a Scottish king being murdered on stage. I'm sure.
这不是一件好事。我的意思是，你想想詹姆士一世（苏格兰的詹姆士六世）以及他母亲的经历。我的意思是，他的母亲被处决了……好了，这里有一个来自SO3 Clausewitz的问题，
Not a good thing. I mean, you think about James I, James VI of Scotland and the experience of his mother. I mean, his mother executed... Okay, so we've got a question here from SO3 Clausewitz,
节目的老朋友。莎士比亚笔下的麦克白夫人对后人对野心勃勃、权势强大的女性的看法产生了多大程度的影响？这种塑造对当时观众对他们最近的都铎女王玛丽和伊丽莎白的态度产生了什么影响（如果有的话）？我不知道答案。我本以为莎士比亚会涉足危险的领域，但我想有一种——权势女性的概念，显然是人们心中的想法，这是100年前所没有的，对吧？我的意思是，亨利八世与罗马决裂，
friend of the show. To what extent has Shakespeare's Lady Macbeth coloured subsequent perceptions of ambitious and powerful women? What, if any, impact did this portrayal have on the attitudes of contemporary audiences to their recently Tudor queens Mary and Elizabeth? I don't know the answer to that. I'd have thought Shakespeare would have been straying into dangerous waters there, but I guess there's a kind of... The idea of the powerful woman, obviously, is on people's minds in a way that it wouldn't have been 100 years earlier, right? I mean, Henry VIII broke with Rome
因为他认为没有哪个女人能够毫无争议地统治英格兰。然后两个女人做到了。接着，16世纪后半叶另一个光芒四射的迷人女主角——苏格兰女王玛丽，是詹姆士的母亲，她卷入了无数的阴谋，并被处决了。所以作为一个角色，这种形象存在于空气中是合情合理的事情。所以这是一部极其政治化的
because he believed no woman could rule England unchallenged. Then two women do. And then the great other glamorous kind of heroine of the second half of the 16th century, Mary, Queen of Scots, is James's mother, and she's involved in a billion plots, and she's executed. So it kind of makes sense that it's in the ether as a character. So it's an incredibly political
戏剧，是的，这是一部非常政治化的戏剧。而且我的确认为麦克白夫人——是的，我的意思是她显而易见的模范我认为是克莉奥佩特拉，也就是罗马人眼中那种被野心冲昏头脑、疯狂且具有怪物般妖魔化特质的女性形象，她驱使着这位高尚的男子、这位高尚的将军，但他有一个弱点，他很软弱，基本上是个妻管严，被她拖入了深渊。
play yeah it's a very political play and i think i do think the lady macbeth and yeah i mean the obvious model for her i think is cleopatra the idea that i did that the romans had of the sort of demonic monstrous woman crazed with ambition who drives the noble man this noble general but he's got one factor for it, he's weak he's basically he's henpecked and drags him down
有趣的是，这种原型从那以后一直流传下来——所以麦克白夫人……希拉里·克林顿在20世纪90年代被人们说成是比尔·克林顿的“麦克白夫人”式人物，谢丽·布莱尔也是，现在呢——你知道的，我见过很多次了——鲍里斯·约翰逊的妻子卡莉现在也被描述为麦克白夫人，是王座背后的权势人物，她让他解雇了财政大臣萨吉德·贾维德，诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，这是政治女性不得不忍受的经典——
and what's interesting is that that archetype has endured ever since so Lady Macbeth Hillary Clinton was a Lady Macbeth figure for Bill Clinton people said in the 1990s cherie blair and now you know i've seen it you know lots of times um boris johnson's wife now carrie is described as lady mcbeth the power behind the throne she got him to sack sajid javid as chancellor all this kind of thing i mean this is the classic yeah thing that political
现象，即人们认为她们在幕后以这种密谋的、蜘蛛网般的方式运作，是的，方式，是的，嗯……那么，嗯……你提到了……嗯……纽约的那场风波，是的。还有其他的吗？但你在节目开头也说过，你将要释放——是的，我还有——我袖子里还有其他关于《麦克白》的演出。好吧。那你给我们准备了什么？
women have to have to endure that they if you know that they're working behind the scenes in this conspiratorial kind of spider's web yes way yes um so um you mentioned um the uh the bust up uh in new york yes are there other you but you also at the top of the show said that you were going to unleash. I was, I've got, I've got other performances of Macbeth at my sleeve. Okay. So what have you got for us?
如果我要回去看一部《麦克白》的制作，那就是所谓的《巫毒麦克白》。你知道《巫毒麦克白》吗？不知道。这是奥逊·威尔斯在1936年制作的。我的意思是，奥逊·威尔斯，正如许多听众所知，
So if I was going to go back and see one production of Macbeth, it would be the so-called Voodoo Macbeth. Do you know the Voodoo Macbeth? No. So this was done by Orson Welles in 1936. I mean, Orson Welles, as many listeners will know,
他在四岁左右就开始制作伟大的电影和戏剧了，他制作这个的时候大概二十岁，所以这是在——
was sort of making great films and plays when he was about four and he was twenty I think when he made this so is this before
在引起轰动的人们耳熟能详的广播剧《星球大战》（注：应为《世界大战》）之前还是之后？我想实际上可能是在之前。我认为是在那之前几年，它是
after the war of the worlds on the radio that gets everyone I think it might actually be before I think it's a couple of years before and it's part of
联邦戏剧项目的一部分，这是一个规模宏大的“新政”式的社会民主主义项目，他在哈莱姆区制作了它。他在哈莱姆区上演了一部《麦克白》。
the federal theatre project which is this big kind of new deal kind of social democratic programme and he does it in Harlem. He puts on a production of Macbeth in Harlem.
他说他想把背景设定在海地。所以麦克白是一个掌权奴隶国王。他使用了全黑人演员阵容，有150人。所以邓肯是白人吗？不，他们全都是黑人。全都是黑人。全都是黑人。起初，在哈莱姆区势力很大的当地共产党
And he says he wants to set it in Haiti. So Macbeth is a kind of slave king who's taken power. He has a black cast, 150 people. So it's Duncan White? No, they're all black. They're all black. They're all black. And at first, the local Communist Party, very big in Harlem,
对此提出抗议，说他在剥削黑人劳动力。他将把黑人展现得形象不佳，这有点在取笑黑人。但事实上，在首演之夜过后，它获得了巨大的成功。听众们可以在网上查到，哈莱姆区交通完全瘫痪的惊人照片，人们都渴望能买票进去看。
protests against it and says, no, he's exploiting black labour. He's going to show black people in a bad light and it's sort of making fun of black people. But actually, after the first night, it's a tremendous success. And you can see online, listeners can look it up, amazing photos of Harlem basically gridlocked, people desperate to get into it.
天哪，二十岁的时候就能有这样的成就，真是太棒了。你当时是个二十岁的导演。《巫毒麦克白》是一部具有里程碑意义的戏剧。我的意思是，很显然，你现在大概真的没法演了。有些人会取消它。但是，不，这是一个——
God, how brilliant to have that when you're 20. You're a 20-year-old director. It's a landmark play, The Voodoo Macbeth. I mean, obviously, you probably couldn't really do it now. It would be cancelled for some. But, no, that's a...
此外，还有另一个20世纪30年代与之相关的《麦克白》制作，很有趣，那就是肖斯塔科维奇——德米特里·肖斯塔科维奇的歌剧《姆岑斯克的麦克白夫人》，取材于19世纪的小说，把麦克白的故事
And there's also another 1930s sort of related Macbeth production which is interesting so Shostakovich's Dmitri Shostakovich's opera Lady Macbeth of Matsensk so there's a 19th century novel taking the Macbeth story
背景设定在俄罗斯。这部歌剧被肖斯塔科维奇视为一部伟大的作品，这就是斯大林去看的那部作品，但他不喜欢它，因为他不喜欢里面的前卫音乐，于是他中途退场了。所以他是个极端的保守派，他是一个巨大的——在艺术上斯大林极其保守，但斯大林也喜欢某种莎士比亚的作品，他喜欢——你知道的，这种类型的东西，所以他对肖斯塔科维奇的歌剧感到震惊，
and setting it in kind of Russia this opera which Shostakovich regards as a great work this is the work that Stalin goes to see and he doesn't like it because he doesn't like it's avant-garde music and he walks out so he's a massive conservative he is a massive well artistically Stalin's incredibly conservative but also Stalin likes kind of Shakespeare and he likes you know this kind of stuff so he's a he's
随后《真理报》谴责了肖斯塔科维奇。肖斯塔科维奇因为创作现代主义垃圾而生活在恐惧之中——现代主义垃圾和肖斯塔科维奇的歌剧。随后《真理报》谴责了肖斯塔科维奇。肖斯塔科维奇因创作现代主义垃圾而生活在恐惧之中。现代主义垃圾。然后肖斯塔科维奇回过头去，最终创作了——我想是他的《第五交响曲》，那是一种更符合斯大林喜好的传统音乐。所以这是另一个有趣的制作。我其实还有一个关于《麦克白》的故事。
appalled by Shostakovich's opera and afterwards Pravda condemns Shostakovich Shostakovich is in fear for writing writing modernist rubbish modernist rubbish and Shostakovich's opera. And afterwards Pravda condemns Shostakovich. Shostakovich is in fear of his life. For writing modernist rubbish. Modernist rubbish. And Shostakovich then goes back and ends up writing, I think it's his Fifth Symphony, much more kind of traditional music that Stalin likes. So that's another interesting production. I have one more Macbeth story, actually.
它就在我袖子里。大约二十年前左右，我曾在爱丁堡艺术节上参演过一部戏剧，你演过吗？关于——是吉恩·安·威斯扮演贝克特，
It's on my sleeve. So about 20-odd years ago, I once did a play at the Edinburgh Festival did you? about it was Jean-Anne Weese played Beckett
关于托马斯·贝克特——听了你读开场白的方式，人们不知道的是，多米尼克花了大约十次才录好那个片段，因为他一直在笑场。
about Thomas Beckett having heard the way you read opening lines and what people don't know is that it took Dominic about 10 goes to do that because he kept corpsing
对，我确实这样了，或者我在模仿各种苏格兰口音。所以我在剧中扮演贝克特，我想只得了两颗星，而《苏格兰人报》给出了五星。好吧。等我们演完之后，
yeah I did or I was doing various Scottish accents so I played Beckett in this play got I think two stars and the Scotsman had a five. Okay. And once we'd done it,
这是一场学生戏剧，我们再也没提过它。然后多年以后，自我即将开始攻读博士学位时，我接到了一个随机的电话，打电话来的是这部剧的导演。他说：“我正准备把一部《麦克白》制作带去美国，
sort of student play, we never spoke of it again. Then many years later, I got a random phone call when I was about to start doing my PhD and it was the director of this play. And he said, I am about to take a production to America of um of macbeth and we've got stilt
我们有高跷步行者，这是一场声势浩大的制作，我们有很多资金，其中一名演员在最后一分钟退出了，基本上我绝望透顶。我们周一就要出发，去美国巡演六个月，你能加入这个制作吗？”我说：“那我演谁呢？”他说：
walkers it's a huge thing we've got lots of money and one of the actors has dropped out the last minute and basically i'm utterly desperate we're leaving on monday we'll be gone for six months touring america which could you join the production and i said well who would i be playing and he said said, Macbeth. Oh, Dominic. And I didn't do it. Now, here's the thing. You turned it down.
“麦克白。”哦，多米尼克。我没有去。现在，重点来了。你拒绝了。
Now, here's the thing. That man went on to direct Paddington and Paddington 2. Oh, Dominic. So if I'd only played my cards right, I would have been Paddington, and you'd be doing this with Ben Whishaw. Hollywood's Dominic Sandbrook. Yeah.
现在，重点来了。那个人后来去执导了《帕丁顿熊》和《帕丁顿熊2》。哦，多米尼克。所以我要是当时动动脑筋，我本可以成为帕丁顿熊，而你现在就会和本·威士肖一起做这个节目了。好莱坞的多米尼克·桑德布鲁克。是的。
Well, I mean, having heard you read, do you want to just do it with a Scottish accent? Because it's... My Scottish accent is shocking. No, but go on. What rhubarb senna or what purgative drug will scour these English ends? Well, so that, I think, leads us on very neatly to the idea that Macbeth is
好吧，我的意思是，听了你朗读之后，你要不要干脆用苏格兰口音来读？因为这——我的苏格兰口音太糟糕了。不，不过说下去。什么大黄、番泻叶或是泻药能洗净这些英国的积弊？好吧，所以这我认为非常巧妙地把我们引向了这样一个观点：《麦克白》
a cursed play. So we've got lots had loads of questions about that so Julian Lennock speaking for many many others what is the story behind the play being cursed uh Julian's mum is an actress and only refers to it as she's Chilean and spits and knocks on wood if you say its name but don't people walk around the theater and they turn around three times and something like that you have to swear or something she's Chilean and spits and knocks on wood if you say its name but don't people walk around the theatre and they turn around three times
是一部受诅咒的戏剧。所以我们收到了很多关于这方面的问题——朱利安·伦诺克代表了许许多多的人问：这部剧被诅咒背后的故事是什么？朱利安的妈妈是一名演员，只要提到它的名字，她就只会称其为“那个剧”，而且如果说了它的名字，她会吐口水并敲木头。难道人们不是在剧院里走来走去，然后转三圈之类的吗？你必须发誓或者做点什么——她来自智利，只要提到它的名字，她就会吐口水并敲木头，但人们难道不在剧院里走来走去并转三圈，
and have to swear or something something like that so I read online and doing my intensive research that this is because provincial plays
还得发誓或者做点别的诸如此类的事吗？我上网做密集研究时读到，这是因为地方剧团
used to put on Macbeth when they were running out of money that's what it says in Wikipedia yeah not true according to you
在资金快用完时就会上演《麦克白》，维基百科上就是这么写的，是的，根据你的说法这不是真的。
well so I'm drawing on James Shapiro okay he's probably a more authoritative who i think i think must have written about the bust up in new york because he wrote a whole book about american reactions to shakespeare which i haven't read but i have read his book on 1606 the year of king lear yeah which is also the year of macbeth and he writes loads about macbeth so i i checked
好吧，所以我是借鉴了詹姆斯·夏皮罗的观点——好吧，他可能是一个更具权威性的人，我想他一定写过关于纽约那场风波的文章，因为他写了一整本关于美国对莎士比亚反应的书，我没读过，但我读过他写的关于1606年（李尔王之年，也是《麦克白》之年）的书，里面写了大量关于《麦克白》的内容，所以我查证过，
it and he says that um the origins of this curse is as late as the um it's the end of the 19th century and it originates with max beer boom who's writing a review of a play and he just for fun he makes up a story that he attributes to john aubrey the um the 17th century brief lives brief lives guy who actually lived in broadsville the village where i grew up so we're very proud of him anyway so he fabricates a story which he attributes to John Aubrey. But the boy who was playing Lady Macbeth gets sick. Yeah. And so Shakespeare himself has to step in to play Lady Macbeth.
他说这个诅咒的起源其实很晚，大约在19世纪末，它起源于马克斯·比尔博姆，他当时在写一篇戏剧评论，他只是为了好玩编造了一个故事，并把它归咎于约翰·欧布瑞——17世纪《简明传记》的作者，而欧布瑞实际上住在布罗德斯韦尔，也就是我长大的那个村子，所以我们无论如何都为他感到自豪。不管怎样，他虚构了一个故事，并把它安在了约翰·欧布瑞头上。但扮演麦克白夫人的小男孩生病了。是的。所以莎士比亚本人不得不亲自上阵扮演麦克白夫人。
And obviously Shakespeare has a beard. You know, he's bald. He's unconvincing. He's unconvincing he's unconvincing um and uh so this is the origins of the curse well that's it that's that's not much of a curse yes it's it's um it's and and that's where that's apparently where it begins that's where the story begins from but there well but obviously he's going with the grain of the fact that that are all these witches and devils and the smoke of thunder. Well, you're quoting James Shapiro's version. The version I read came from Sir Donald Sinden.
显然莎士比亚留着胡子。你知道的，他秃顶。他演得毫无说服力。他毫无说服力，他演得毫无说服力，嗯……所以这就是诅咒的起源。好吧，这就完了——这算不上什么诅咒，是的，它就是——这就是它的起源，故事就是从那里开始的。不过，当然，他顺应了这样一个事实：剧中到处都是女巫、恶魔以及雷电交加的烟雾。好吧，你引用的是詹姆斯·夏皮罗的版本。我读到的版本来自唐纳德·辛登爵士。
Yeah, well, I'd back James Shapiro. Sir Donald Sinden. Sir Donald Sinden any time. So I reckon that's it. And I reckon we've done Macbeth now, haven't we? We have. I think that world of Scottish politics in the Middle Ages, I mean, you're welcome to return to it at your leisure. It is interesting, though, don't you think?
是的，好吧，我支持詹姆斯·夏皮罗。任何时候我都支持唐纳德·辛登爵士。唐纳德·辛登爵士。所以我想就是这样。我想我们现在已经把《麦克白》聊完了，不是吗？是的。我想中世纪苏格兰政治的那片天地——我的意思是，欢迎你们随时重回那个话题。不过它很有趣，不是吗？
I think it is interesting. It is, you know, for the whole future of the United Kingdom. And the fact that it kind of, you know, the idea of Scotland begins in such a kind of complex, tortuous, twisted way. And it's exactly the same with English identity. Of course it is. Of all national identities. I mean, I think that Scottish identity is kind of weaker than English identity for quite a while. And it's really the English invasions that really consolidates it and kind of prompts the construction of this backstory, which basically shunts Paul Macbeth to one side.
我认为它很有趣。它对于整个联合王国的未来而言——而且它以一种如此复杂、曲折、盘根错节的方式开始，这真是——英国的身份认同也完全一样，当然是的。所有的国家认同都是如此。我的意思是，我认为苏格兰的身份认同在相当长的一段时间里比英格兰的身份认同要弱，真正巩固它并促成这种背景故事构建的，其实是英格兰的入侵，而这种背景故事基本上把真实的麦克白推到了一边。
Yes, it's weird, isn't it? Macbeth is probably the single best known. Do you think it's the best known or sort of artistic depiction of Scottishness over the centuries? It's certainly the most famous depiction of a Scottish king, isn't it? Yeah.
是的，这很奇怪，不是吗？《麦克白》可能是最广为人知的——你认为它是几个世纪以来最著名的苏格兰特色艺术描绘吗？它当然是关于苏格兰国王最著名的描绘，不是吗？是的。
Other than Braveheart, which I know you're... I think it's more famous than Braveheart. Yeah, let's hope so anyway. Anyway, I think that's enough Macbethery. It is. So we will say goodbye. And what are we doing next? I can't remember.
除了《勇敢的心》，我知道你对那部电影——我认为它比《勇敢的心》更著名。是的，无论如何希望如此。不管怎样，我想关于麦克白的讨论就到这里吧。是的。所以我们要说再见了。我们接下来要做什么？我记不清了。
Oh, we've got Mary Beard talking about classics. Yes, very exciting. Coming on Thursday. Yeah. So Beard talking about classics. Yes. Very exciting. Coming on Thursday. Yeah. So we will see you then. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to the Rest is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哦，我们请到了玛丽·比尔德来谈论古典学。是的，非常令人兴奋。周四播出。是的。所以比尔德将谈论古典学。是的。非常令人兴奋。周四播出。是的。那我们到时候见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。想要获取独家单集、提前收听权限、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。